welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day 29 and
we're gonna learn how
billionaires think about risk enjoy
[Music]
i seem to have a high innate drive
[Music]
and that's been true even since i was a
little kid you know i
really had a very strong drive
did all sorts of risky things when i was
a kid that i like why did i do those
things they're crazy
i wouldn't say i'm fearless in fact i i
think i fear
i feel fear quite strongly uh but i
um if the if if what we're doing isn't
for what you know what i'm doing is i
think is important enough then i just uh
override the fear so but it's not as
though i don't feel i feel
like more strongly than i would like and
in which areas
would you never go full risk if you're
still up here
full
well it really depends on the stakes if
the stakes are high
if it's really important then one should
then i you know will overcome the fear
and just do it anyway
um but essentially i mean i just
drive overrides fear but i feel the fear
it's kind of annoying i
shouldn't okay i wish i felt it less
which company you founded
was the most risky at the start
well probably spacex i thought had the
lowest chance of success
[Music]
i mean i thought both tesla and spacex
would fail at the beginning
you know you saw it yeah sure really of
course
but nevertheless you put all your money
in that both i expected to lose it
well technically what i i thought was
well
i'll take half the money from paypal and
if i lose half of it that's okay
um but then of course the companies
encounter difficulties
and then have a choice so they either
like let the company die
um or put you know all the money
into the companies and so
i really didn't want the companies today
so i put all the money in the companies
yeah and then i had to borrow money for
friends which would pay living expenses
2008 in particular was was was was awful
because um
we had the third launch failure in a row
of of our falcon 1 vehicle at spacex um
and we the tesla financing round that we
were
raising fell apart because the
economy was going to tailspin and it's
pretty hard to raise money for
a startup car company uh you know late
2008 when jim and chrysler are busy
going bankrupt
um that that was that was tough and then
solar city had a deal with
morgan stanley and morgan stanley had to
renege on the deal because they
themselves running out of money um so it
looked like all three companies were
going to die
and i was also going through divorce so
that was definitely a low point
so it's 2008 you're going through a
divorce which like some
to borrow your word douchebag bloggers
are writing about to make even worse
right yes that's true um in addition to
all that stuff happening i was getting
dumped on
massively in the press right yeah you're
you know it looks like all three
companies
yeah are gonna file i mean why do you
keep going with all three
like i feel like even a lot of great
entrepreneurs in that situation would
have been like
i've already sunk everything i have in
these companies
and i gotta pick one but you didn't i
mean you kept doing all three
why um yeah that was that was a very
tough call
um at the end of 2008 that was that was
probably the top
you know one of the toughest goals i've
had to make because i could either
reserve capital for one company
or the other i mean before solar city
didn't need a ton of capital so they
were okay
um but between spacex and and and tesla
um you know it's sort of like like
you've got two kids
and what do you do do you spend all your
money to
to maximize probably the success of of
one or do you
do you try to keep both left
unfortunately it worked one of the most
difficult choices i ever faced
uh in life was was in 2008
um and um
i think i had uh like
maybe 30 million dollars left or 30 or
41 left in 2008 i had two choices
i could put it all into one company
and then the other company would
definitely die um or split it
between the two companies and but if i
split it between two companies then both
might die
um and you know when you put your
blood sweat and tears into creating
something you're building something it's
like a child
um and so
it's like which one am i gonna let one
starve to death
i can bring myself to do it so i split
the money between the two
fortunately thank goodness uh they both
came through you started with a much
smaller rocket of falcon one
and was your goal at that point when you
started with falcon 1
to get to the point where we had nine
engines for falcon 9 was that your goal
at that time
when i started spacex i i only thought
there was maybe a ten percent chance of
getting fell from one to august i did
not at all think that this would happen
uh so this is for sure dream come true
um
uh but i i literally at the time i
didn't know anything about rockets uh
and i was
you know i've been the chief engineer of
spacex since day one
and i don't hear anything about rockets
which is why the first three rockets
failed right
um and then so the first three falcon
ones for space actually
failures yes and then tell me about
uh the the fourth one so
i had actually only had enough money for
three three flights
um so i had no more money after we
managed to the
team sort of rallied and we managed to
put together enough spare parts to pay
to do a fourth launch
and that both launch was successful um
and
uh so what would happen if it wasn't
successful oh we
were spacex for tonight so we would not
be here right now
uh at this moment getting ready to
launch crew dragon to the international
system
in a world that's changing so quickly
the biggest risk you can take is not
taking any risk
and i really think that that's true
right i mean a lot of people i think
think that
um you know whenever it comes to
whenever you get yourself into a
position where you have to
make some some big shift and direction
or do something
um you know they're always people are
going to point to
the the downside risks of that decision
and
locally they're maybe right right i mean
if for any given decision that you're
going to make there's
upside and downside but in aggregate if
you
are stagnant and you don't make those
changes then
then i think you're guaranteed to fail
right and not not catch up so
to some degree i think it's really right
that over time the biggest risk that you
can
take is to not take any risks many of
our parents had stable jobs throughout
their careers but
in our generation we're all a little
entrepreneurial whether we're starting
our own projects or finding our role in
another one
and you know that's great because our
culture of entrepreneurship
is how we create so much progress
an entrepreneurial culture thrives when
it is easy to try
lots of new ideas facebook wasn't the
first thing i built
i also built chat systems and games
study tools and music players and i'm
not alone
jk rowling got rejected 12 times before
she finally wrote and published harry
potter
even beyonce had to make hundreds of
songs to get halo
the greatest successes come from having
the freedom to fail
do you think entrepreneurship is for
everybody no
and why i don't i think you have to be
i'd say the the key
um mindset is the ability to
take risk and be comfortable with taking
risks a lot of people
i find that the difference between doing
it and not doing it is a lot of time it
comes down to risk
when you do something there are so many
unknowns you have to be comfortable with
that
and you have to be comfortable with the
fact that there's a really high
probability that you're going to fail
yeah most people just aren't comfortable
like thinking about
imagine this somebody comes to you and
says listen i want you to absolutely
dedicate your entire life
kill yourself give up family friends
everything and yeah there's a good
chance it's not going to work it's like
that's a tough sell yeah that's a tough
sell for most people
do you think it's the combination of
both talk to me about like risk
the young guy out there how do you how
do you take risk how do you
decide okay i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna go for it this is worth it
how do you how do you uh weigh the the
pros and cons of whatever's coming up
yeah i look i look for opportunities
where their
risk means a low probability success
basically that's what i would kind of
bucket he said it's risky what's a low
probability success but you need to make
sure
that it's a low probability of success
but if it is successful
it's orders of magnitude bigger returns
so so for example you have a 10 shot you
invest a hundred dollars and you have a
10
shot the 100 becomes a million that's a
bet you want to take right because
one in 10 100 becomes a million do that
over and over again
look for opportunities like that it
doesn't make sense to take a risk you
have a 10 shot of success and 100 bucks
becomes a thousand
you're not going to you know that's not
going to not going to work out in the
long term so find
bets that are that have a high expected
value
where the outcomes are outsized relative
to the risk
find those opportunities and then
prepare to take them
over and over again because if you take
those shot ten times and ten percent
there's a good chance one of those will
work out and then you hit the million
dollar outcome
you have to be prepared to go in give it
everything you've got if it fails get
back up
find another opportunity and for me
fortunately
those within each one of my companies
if i continue to go down the path i was
going it would have been
would have been a failure but i saw an
opportunity to take yet another
10 shot in the existing company and i
did it a few times
failed took the shot failed took the
shot failed and then it worked so all
four companies fortunately for me worked
out
but there were failures inside of each
one of them
that could have could have blown up if i
wasn't prepared to like get back up and
go at it again
a fiat x19 that had a hole in the
floorboard i mean you could tell
i was living the high life right i mean
and i was putting in oil every 60 miles
and
you know working as a bartender at night
what did i have to lose
you know and so it wasn't like oh man
you know this is i could lose all this
um and so
yeah and so it was just like you just go
for it
now later on after i'd had some success
and
we got back and we started audionet
which turned into broadcast.com
the the math was different the equations
you know the calculus was different it
was like
okay i'm investing a lot of my saved
money
into this whole idea of net casting
right or internet broadcasting
in early 1995 when people didn't even
know what the internet was
that was all risk because i literally
was putting everything that i had
on the line for something people just
laughed at me and said
wait audio over the internet
you know you can turn on the radio you
know you know you can turn on the tv
yeah but you don't get it no that's just
dumb all right
you know and and so being able to
overcome all that resistance
because remember back then a you had to
have a pc
b you had to know what a modem was and
install it c
you had to know what the internet was
and then you had to download a tcp
client that worked over a modem and then
connected to a browser that you probably
didn't even know what it was
or how to download it and we had to take
it on
faith that all this was going to grow
there's part of you that either
wants to create a business or you
obviously already have created a
business
the hardest part is taking that first
step right there's always that line like
i was talking about earlier
that you have to take a step past but
the thing
people always say well you know you're
not afraid to start a business why why
aren't you
it's terrifying or you know i just it
scares me to do it
and my my attitude has always been if
you're prepared it's not a risk
right bobby knight who was the coach at
indiana university
used to say everybody's got the will to
win but it's only those with the will to
prepare
that do win and the same applies to
business
we've all seen our friends go out there
and just wing it you know it's my
passion
we're all passionate about something i'm
passionate about basketball doesn't make
me an nba player
right it's not just about passion it's
not just about saying i'm doing it it's
not even about
incorporating it's not about the idea
it's about are you prepared and are you
willing to do the work
urgency that i felt that if we didn't
get microsoft going right away that
somebody
uh would do a great job building a
software company we won't have a chance
that probably
ended up not being true that i could
have waited two or three years and the
opportunity to do microsoft still would
be there but
anyway i felt a sense of urgency uh and
you know it's not like you know i still
get to take courses and learn
things um today you know things like the
learning company and there's all sorts
of great books so
it's not like i've missed some part of
my education
when you dropped out your father and
mother said are you sure you know what
you want to do if
one of your children dropped out of
college to start a company what would
you say
well i'd have to say yes but uh the
dropping out is not an irrevocable
decision
uh you know if you try and start a
company it doesn't go well they always
let you go back
uh and so if you don't have you know
kids that you need to uh support
you know it's a very low risk thing
particularly in the
culture of the united states where
trying to start something
and failing is not a black mark for the
rest of your life
part of the thing that drives computer
science forward is
is doing risky things having a long term
time horizon
and when microsoft was a small company
we benefited from the fact that
a t and xerox and other companies had
made
investments in research that they'd
reached out and worked
with universities on a broad basis so we
felt very lucky that as we got
to a certain level of success we could
start our own research group
and have that research group be in
partnership with top universities all
over the world doing
advanced programming programs things
that range from
the work on speech recognition all the
way up to quantum computing
we have a fairly serious program that
has a you know high risk of failure
uh which makes it fun and interesting on
quantum computing and you know even in
the best case it's probably
a decade away before that makes a
difference but that's the kind of thing
that when it works can have incredibly
high payoff being an entrepreneur is
about taking risks but it's about taking
very calculated risks
and being you know protecting the
downside so i didn't quit my job selling
fax machines
until i had already invented the product
i was working on it at night and on the
weekends
for two years i was driving around north
carolina where most hosiery was made
begging a bunch of manufacturing plants
to help make it
and i didn't quit my job until i had
already landed neiman marcus saks fifth
avenue and got a call from oprah
just a typical day then i was like okay
i feel confident to quit but i needed
the income that was coming in and i
needed my health care benefits and i
was working out of my apartment in
virginia highlands and i ran spanx
out of my apartment for two and a half
years
and it was crazy i mean i'd semi trucks
pulling up twice a week to this
apartment
and my neighbors were like what's
happening what's going on but i was so
conservative with
my finances in the beginning i was very
scrappy and still am
really scrappy one of the things when i
really sit and think
why am i comfortable taking risks what
is it yeah um
where i come from i was really lucky
when i was growing up my dad
used to actually encourage my brother
and me to fail
and so i would come home and sit at the
dinner table and he would say
sarah what did you fail at this week and
if i didn't have something he would
actually be disappointed
and i can vividly remember coming home
and saying dad dad i tried out for this
and i was horrible and he would
high-five me
and what i i didn't realize that's so
awesome i didn't realize it at the time
but it was
he was teaching us that failure is is
not trying versus the outcome
and so with spanx and everyone saying it
was such a bad idea initially
and you know i feel like i feel much
freer to be willing to
you know fail in the traditional sense
because i'm not focused on the
end result and the more it's like
working a muscle the more you're willing
to
risk something and maybe fail you
realize there's always a really awesome
hidden gift in it
it's either you meet someone new that
brings you to a different place in your
life or you learn something new
or and and so i always was really
excited by
what how my life grew by every risk i
took when i started my business
1995 it was very difficult
i had an idea i invited 24 of my friends
my apartment
because that year i went to seattle
first time my first trip to the usa
in seattle i discovered internet
and i think this thing in the future may
change the world
tell me about the encounter with the
internet when you first saw it yeah i
went to the
seattle and a friend of mine he had a
small office with like a four or five
computers
i never touched computer in my life
before because computer was so expensive
to me
and so complicated but my friend said
this is internet just
typing whatever word you want to type
it's a no no too expensive i don't know
which one to do even now i don't know
how a computer works
but he said jack it's not a bomb just a
typo whatever so the first award i typed
in was a beer
b-e-i beer i don't drink i don't know
why a type of beer
i found american beer german beer
japanese beer no china so i typed the
word
china there's no information about
china so i say what if we can make some
china information on the internet
let people know about china so that was
the idea
so i came back to china and say i want
to resign
from my school you're a teacher i was a
teacher
i've been teaching in the university for
six years
so i said i want to do it i invite 24 of
my friends to my apartment
after two hours of explaining what i'm
going to do
internet and 23 of them say forget it
he said this thing never worked because
there's no such thing called
internet in the world you know nothing
about a computer
so why you want to do this and um
only one people he said jack
if you want to try it just to try it but
if it's something wrong just
come back and uh after
whole night thinking i say i still want
to do it
because most of the people they have a
fancy ideas in the evening but in the
day
when they wake up in the evening on the
morning they go back to do the same job
we have to do something different so
from there
i started my business borrowing 2000 us
dollars from my relatives and friends
that was my trip i call myself
like a blind man riding on the back of
blind tigers
and those people who are expert of
riding horses they all fall down
and i'm still surviving you're doing
very well out there you're now living in
san francisco area
you're making a big success you're by
investment banking standards i presume
you're
you know highly compensated so forth
what propelled you to say i'm going to
give all this
up and go start my own company right so
the interesting
thing that occurred as you know again as
an engineer the thing i
realized way back in my goodyear and
tire and rubber days the impact
that software really had on businesses
the thing that i noticed that there's
very few software companies were
actually efficiently run
well why the big part was most
executives who started software
companies well
they wrote code or they knew a market
opportunity and they sold the codes
there was never anyone who taught them
how to run software companies
so i then run into this the small
company i'll say small in
in houston texas that is the most
efficient software company i've ever
seen
they had some very basic things that
they just did extremely well
and i said well if you took those basic
things in and actually applied them
ultimately to other enterprise software
companies you could run those businesses
very similar to the way they ran theirs
and would create tremendous value in
those companies
that that was the idea that was a
conceit and they said that's a good idea
why don't you do it
well yeah in essence they said well if
you actually thought about
taking some of these best practices and
putting in buying enterprise software
companies and
driving them forward you could actually
do pretty well and i said that's great
idea would you do that and i said well
you know they gave me one of those
offers that looked quite interesting and
i remember my lawyer said this is a bad
deal robert but you should take it
right so you went to goldman and said
i'm leaving right did they try to talk
you out of it
of course of course they made the pitch
against it but you know i like all
things david
at some point in time in your life you
know you got to look yourself in the
mirror and said you know
you have to take a little risk and go
see if this is something
were you when you took this i was 39
years old and it's
so interesting so of course i started
doing research it was the same age that
others
left what they were doing to go start
their businesses so i said well let's go
give it a run
dc we had a really interesting situation
uh we went there
by the way we're as far as we could tell
we are totally legal
white glove legal nicest laws in the
country in terms of sedans
in dc but dc taxi commissioner
goes out there and says uber's not legal
because they charge by time and distance
and let's just say that was real
why is charging by distance evil
i don't understand i don't get it
but he said look you're charging my time
and distance you're not allowed well we
looked at the law
law says sedan a four-higher vehicle
designed to carry fewer than six
passengers which charges for
service on the basis of time and mileage
like what are you talking about he's
going in public forums washington post
et cetera
we go the attorney general in the
district of columbia
and that's what he tells us
so when you read about the crazy stuff
we're doing in the cities and i've got
to close this down because i'm
somebody's going to have the hook and
they're going to take me off here
but when you read about the crazy stuff
that we're doing in the cities
know that it is corrupt out there
know that we are highly highly
disruptive and what you read in the
papers isn't always true
and the bottom line is that in order to
be in this business
in order to be this disruptive to what's
going on you have to have
you have to be willing to fight
and you have to not be you can't be shy
so that gives you a little bit about it
basically they tried to put a floor on
our prices i'll leave it at this one
this last one here
they put a floor on our prices or tried
to pass what they called the uber
amendment
make our prices five times out of a taxi
they rolled the amendment out july 10th
that was a monday
sorry uh july 9th the vote on the bill
was
the 10th sorry they put the bill out on
the night that was a monday at 4 pm
to vote on at 11am the next day 18 hours
most of which you're going to be
sleeping
i wrote an email to our consumers
letting them know that they're about to
do this
and by the way the rationale was to
ensure that basically we don't compete
if a ceo of a company told said
something like this they'd be in jail
but if you corrupt your politicians and
then push those laws down it's totally
legal
anyways we did something called life
liberty in the pursuit of uberness
uberdc love was a hashtag 18 hours later
we had 50 000 original emails these
weren't robo emails
that went to city council people telling
them not to vote for it 37
000 tweets 104 million social media
impressions
and we won and
as you might imagine there wasn't a lot
of sleep during that time
but it was so short it maybe didn't
matter you will have many of many many
opportunities
opportunities to reinvent yourself and
so
uh you know so i think you know it's
worthwhile taking risks
and trying to do something you're really
uh you know excited by
and if the first attempt you don't do it
you know you can try again and you know
things tend to work
out in the long run in silicon valley
you know uh you know part of the reason
so many people
start up a company is you know starting
up a company and even having failed you
know you can wear it like a badge of
honor
right and uh i think that's important
you know culturally you know
risk is rewarded i remember when i
started working at google
you know i if if i went and you know
people were discussing ideas
the other people who heard the ideas try
to build on those ideas they encourage
you
so it's a culture of optimism it's a
culture of risk-taking and i think
that's really important being in the u.s
you know i find people
take a remarkably varied number of paths
and
uh you know so i do think it's important
to follow your dream
and do something which you're you know
excited by
you know so i think if you follow your
heart and do what you like
you will always do much better uh and so
i don't think it matters that you're an
engineer or
uh you're uh you know you're in science
or it could be in
any field as a business grows the
natural tendency would be
to take fewer risks and to be cautious
and to have contingency plans but in a
business that's changing very quickly or
one that you want to grow
you actually need to be explicit about
accepting risk
one of the people who work with me
kind of described it this way they you
know i was sort of encouraging this
person hey you know let's try this why
don't we do this how about this and
at some point he kind of came back and
said so what you're telling me is
you want me to try to do 10 things
and if i only get eight of them you know
you'll be okay with that
you know if i don't get all you know all
10 versus
you know having five things and doing
all five perfectly that's exactly right
you know
you know we we want to accept some
experiments
we have i mean we have our own jargon to
some extent like for example
somebody comes to me the project or a
product that we're going to go sell
or or some some project i ask them is it
slam dunk
you know and no it's really good i said
no no
is it slam dunk so but but it really
it's a good product
and what it does is it totally clarifies
their mind
that oh no it's not slam dunk then then
i say well
why are we going to do it so our
standards are high
we have these simple things which which
uh clarify the mind not totally
you know mess up your mind or
have so much jargon that nobody knows
what you're talking about but
you got all the right words like equal
ecosystem whatever
uh you know everybody's got ecosystems
here you know or
uh you know value propositions no no no
guys just good sell good stuff to people
who need it
you know so all of that jargon all it
does is bury common sense
uh so the idea is you get simple
uh somebody asked me you know in the
interview i said what what does an
entrepreneur really need so i said the
only two things
common sense and a sense of urgency
that's it
and they asked me who should we learn
this stuff for and
my answer was from your mom
because she's probably done more
management
than your mba professor
you know
because she's got a budget
you've got all these kids running around
hard to manage
all of this thing has to be done every
day seven days a week
now that's work that's hard work that's
learning on the job
and people say oh she's just a homemaker
that's a that's like a lowly thing no
it's not
that's that's great media and people say
oh no you know
you're saying well women should be
homemakers no no that's the most that's
the hardest work there is it's the most
talent
you need us the guys go out there and
work eight hours that
any idiot can do that
[Applause]
so it's it's sort of thinking
based on description in other words
if you look at any word and you really
think about it then you understand it
otherwise you just use these words that
everybody uses and and they think okay
now this guy must know something after
all he
you know he knows what an ecosystem is
so
our approach to things like i said is is
different you may agree with it i'm sure
i'm going to get some
mba professor to i mean one time the u
of m uh
university of michigan law school called
me to speak i said you guys kidding
so i said i you know i think of mbas i
think it's totally useless
um so he said no no come over so i said
fine
that's what you want so
i went over there and kind of defined it
i said look i mean i'm not saying
that they don't teach anything of value
i mean i think they teach this much
that is useful they teach this much that
is useless
and then they teach this much that's
harmful
yeah so overall you know averages
on the useless side because you come out
of school
and you actually think you know
something really
you know and that's dangerous because
you really don't
so i never hire people out of fancy
schools for that reason
my first question usually is to an mba
how are you going to get over it
[Applause]
so and i'm not i'm i'm really not alone
in this
the good guys i've met the chief
executives i've met of really large
companies that are you know that don't
usually they get in front of podium and
it's all pc
lawyer you know lawyer cleared stuff so
they don't say anything
but the good guys that i've met they're
all sick of mbas
really uh they're not really enamored of
this whole thing because
you know look it's a simple thing if
you're going to learn plumbing
go learn from a plumber that's actually
seen a pipe
you know has fixed a leak not just
written about pipes and
lectured on pipes and research pipes
yeah it's it's
[Applause]
so i i'm not for theoretical plumbers
the average person who's listening too
many people
think that they can go into this very
difficult zero-sum
game of betting against the consensus
and be right
you know what i mean in other words
investors says i'm going to go in the
markets i'm going to make money
betting against the consensus and be
right right because the consensus is
built into the price
okay okay that's what's up so it's think
of it as like going to a horse race
and there's handicaps okay you're not
going to pick the best horse
and you're not going to pick the best
company a terrible company can be a
better investment than a
uh a terrific company a terrible company
could be a better investment just like
the terrible horse
can be a better because the odds that
are
changing like you go into that and that
becomes the long shot
but because the long shot is going to
pay off 25 to 1
right if he comes in that
um you could just as likely bet on the
the long shot
as the leader and it's going to be
equally likely that you're going to make
money right
otherwise you'd otherwise the market
would be doing the opposite
well the market is like that right in
other words if everybody believes that
something's going to be terrific
okay then everybody's betting on it and
its price is high
so it's not what's best necessarily
it's what's best relative to what's in
the price what's discounting
the chain store bug had already bitten
me right
and it wasn't long as soon as i could
afford it all
i started casting around for another
location
and where did where was that
fayetteville on the square it was that
little 18-foot storm
shotgun 1952 1952 we got
absorbed fayetteville started didn't we
right and it became very successful
so then one day i got a call from ben
franklin and they said
hey we got a store in kansas city and
uh you remember the story i certainly do
and i i thought well if i've got if i've
got to go to kansas city i got to get me
an airplane
and i didn't i had never flown probably
first looked at it in 53 i'd say
uh and this was our first venture in the
shopping center yeah and
there were practically no shopping
centers that's true that's exactly right
and this was something entirely new and
different everybody was skittish of it
no one else wanted the franchise really
one another one of those situations
right and uh but said well i'll take
half of it i think i can put
put enough money together to get half of
it i said well if you can i'll i'll try
to do my part
and we'll go up there and we'll just
take another gamble sure right and it
was a gamble it was out uh
20 miles from the kansas city city
limits time we got this door open
why it was a winner from the day we
opened i mean it was it was the best
profit store i know one year it made
thirty thousand dollars which
was more money than we'd ever heard or
ever dreamed about
being able to make out of one store i
saw a video post the other day about
millionaires are broke or something yeah
on instagram well i can't remember
exactly what it was
like never never take advice never take
advice from a millionaire and and the
reason why is because
you know millionaires are not they're
not certain about their money yet
they're scared actually i mean if you
ask them just go ask them hey
what got you a million dollars i was out
there hustling working deals da da
then when you got a million what
happened you started worrying about
losing it
what do i do with this money and you
start saving it and protecting it you
were taking risks when you were
you had nothing you took a risk when you
had nothing
you took risks when you had 100 took
risk when you had 300 then you quit
taking risks in a million
so that's why i said never take advice
from a millionaire because they're go
they go into conservation mode yeah the
billionaire never goes into conservation
mode
like all the way up he's just like
expansion look at elon
sells paypal walks away with three
million dollars
puts it all in a bing bing bing and
rinse
right rinse where he lifts bored money
to rent
yeah shoved it all in it's crazy
millionaire never do that
why takes all his chips off the table
then then looks at his chips and he's
scared he's gonna lose him again
what's your attitude to fear and risk uh
yeah you gotta you got you gotta you
gotta you gotta
you gotta take risk the the best way to
stay out of harm's way is to be the most
dangerous person in the room
right i like that you know yeah like
yeah do you ever though sometimes think
man i'm taking two bigger risks every
scary
every deal i do yeah every deal it make
you feel alive
no i know i'm alive i i just i just um
you know like when you take on an arena
and you're like i'm gonna book there's
five thousand people here
okay my my my gig
did had seven times that many people 35
000 people
yeah i mean i sold out an arena as big
as jay-z and beyonce would sell out
the difference is i had them there for
three days they have them there for two
hours
on super bowl weekend our biggest
football you know you guys
laugh at our football but we love it
right so so
the biggest uh sports weekend
in the united states of america is super
bowl weekend i held my event on that
weekend
freaking insane so i'm just going to
look it up just so i don't i'm an
entrepreneur
yeah okay you know what you ever looked
it up i i kind of know intuitively
someone who starts businesses and you
know person who organizes and operates a
business or business is taking on
listen but this is the important part
this is good for your young viewer
taking on greater than normal financial
risk in order to do so
by definition the second half of that
most people are not entrepreneurs
because they never take on any risk
like they're they're holding on to their
money they got cash in the banks they
got equity in their houses
they're saving money saving for
retirement if you're doing any of that
versus putting the balls against the
wall right you're like what are you
doing dude you're more committed
people are more committed to the equity
in their home than they are to the
equity of their brand or business
so i made this mistake for years in your
own life yeah
you must operate okay you must operate
like your life depends on it
okay life-threatening life-threatened
i operate best when i am under a threat
time threat financial threat uh
threat to lose something there's got to
be a loss for you to stay on your game
this is why i tell so many people get
your money out of the bank and get it
back into the marketplace
do not have cash sitting in the bank
cash in the bank is
exactly what your mom and daddy told you
it was it is an emergency
a security blanket why johnny has money
in
in the wall of his house is because he
first had this idea
i'm gonna put money there to avoid the
ir and the s
and number two i'm gonna have it there
just in case i need it i'll go get me a
little two inches or whatever i need of
it okay
johnny's got to get that money out of
the wall out of the bank
okay and back into the system so it pays
him today i want to talk to you about
financial offense
financial offense i just finished
watching brazil
beat uh costa rica costa rica
seven minutes into the deal i'm like
there's no way costa rica wins this
okay uh 48 minutes there is
it's going to be impossible it was still
0-0 it would be impossible for costa
rica
to win even though the refs and by the
way this is
all about life right here right now even
though the refs were making
consistently bad calls against
brazil i knew that costa rica would win
how do i know that even though the calls
were bad
okay literally 90 minutes into the game
i am still confident i think it was 88
minutes into the game
0-0 i become more and more confident
that brazil will beat costa rica
the score ended up 2-0 brazil why was i
right
because brazil was on offense the entire
game so i know a lot of you guys a lot
of you guys
uh in america don't like uh hockey or
soccer because you're like
dude it's just too slow dude it's too
slow do the games i'm believing
okay terrible game if you're not on
offense same thing with money
if you want money you have to get on
offense okay
i was brought up to stay on defense in
my finances
if you play defense and finances not
only will you never have money
even if you did have it you would be one
of those people that nobody likes
you don't want to be that guy why is it
by the way i was that guy
and every every time i come to you and
talk to you and share with you a show
anytime i'm talking to you about
anything anytime any of you see me
slamming on somebody if you think i'm
talking about somebody else you're wrong
it's always me i'm talking about
i only share experiences i've had i was
that guy
okay i was the mooch what do you call
them again
[Music]
pecano the kanyo cheap
bastard i was that guy for 20 years
because i was playing defense with my
finances i was brought up to play
defenses with my finances
my mother taught me to play defense with
my finances you know why
because she did not know how to play
offense
[Music]
i was watching an old sugar ray sugar
ray leonard uh
roberto duran fight it was the third
time they met
roberto duran the entire fight all 12
rounds was doing nothing but playing
defense you cannot win
boxing match if you're not on offense
you cannot win a
soccer game if you're not on offense and
you will not
win the finance game playing defense
what does defense look like to this guy
this guy's saving money okay he won't
spend money
he probably measures roi on everything
he looks at everything from what's the
return gonna be what's the deal gonna be
these are mistakes by the way
i'm gonna spend three hours talking
about this in miami next friday
live right here in miami i'm gonna spend
three hours talking about how do you get
out of this mooch mode what do you call
it again
that ganya how do you get out of takanya
mode
out of mooch mode out of defense mode
okay the millionaire next door
the book the the book millionaire next
door literally misguided
hundreds of millions of people save your
way
to being a millionaire folks you don't
want to be a millionaire okay
and you don't want to save your way to
get there because the millionaire that
saves their money and won't spend their
money
is not even using money for the very
purpose it was created
money is to be used and not stored
okay the reason i'm having financial
success in my life today is not because
i play defense
but because i spend my time on offense
i wake up in the morning with a goal
hey what is my financial target today
two the rest of the day i spend saying
who's got my money i spend all my time
saying who's got my money who's got my
money
and the third thing i do is i invest my
money
okay we have seven businesses here today
i have one of these seven businesses
that will make me more money for the
next hundred years
than the other six combined did in their
entire career
why because it's indestructible wealth
so you got to have a goal
that's offense right i'm trying to get
the ball in the net
if i'm trying to get the ball in the net
i can't play defense i need to move the
ball to the other side of the field and
kick
into the net brazil had 16 attempts on a
net
costa rica had one attempt you can't win
playing defense
you have to kick which means you got to
go for it you got to use money okay
so you need a goal then you need to go
hey man how do i use money to get money
how do i get some money from somebody
and use that money
to then invest in something that will
reproduce money
when you take money and put in the bank
you know what it produces nothing
if you're down to cutting corners to
make sense of something
don't buy it if you're having to lease
something
for extra 12 months to afford it it's
the wrong thing to do
okay quit doing it like i don't put my
money in anything that doesn't make
money i'll tell you right now
if it doesn't make me money if it
doesn't have the potential
to get me a score i'm not running a ball
down the field
i don't lose money man okay look i go
out i don't lose time either i go to the
marketplace to get money
i have a goal every day okay i have a
gold monthly i have a goal
annually i have a goal over my lifetime
if i want to do the math on something i
do the math okay
i've done this my whole life i did it on
100 grand
i did it on 1 million my first million
i did it on 100 million
okay and now i'm doing it since i've
accomplished these i'm going to do it on
1 billion
this is how you set goals the goal is
this man i want to make a billion
dollars how many people do i need
to contact on the planet first a goal
a goal an achievable goal is it
achievable so then i do the math i'm
like wait a minute man
how could i do it oh if 10 000 people
i'm sorry if a hundred thousand people
how many is it yeah if a hundred
thousand people
gave me ten thousand dollars
would have one billion bucks
now the question is now that i got the
billion how do i keep it
[Music]
and how do i not go to jail like like
you can't just take people's money and
not give them something back
oh wow what could i invest in so i don't
lose the money
i don't want to lose the money so i need
to put the money in something
where it's not at risk where i'm not
speculating where i don't lose my
reputation
my dad used to tell me son if you want
to have good things in life
never ruin one thing your reputation
once you ruin your reputation man you're
going to spend all your time and energy
and money
trying to fix your reputation so you
guys see me every day everything i do is
out there and they open wide open i buy
a plane you get to see it
i buy an office building you get to see
it i'm buying this office right now you
anything you see with me with my kids
with my money at a conference
this is this isn't this isn't make
believe this is real okay
i showed you how do i make a hundred
grand when i'm trying i'm broke
how do i make a hundred thousand dollars
oh i need 1 000 people
to give me 100 i i need to get people to
know me
okay you see what you guys do is y'all
go
oh god i got to get an app i got to
build an
app my friend my friend over the barber
over here javier okay
i'm gonna build an app i'm gonna build
an app dude you don't need to build
anything you need to go talk to people
that's why i go to conference that's why
i do come
that's why we're about to take 10x
growth conference to all major cities in
the united states why
because i want to meet you guys you guys
come up to me you're like can i take a
photo
please take a photo with me i want the
photo man
i need to meet you guys i want to meet
you why do you think i open the fun up
because i want to meet people
my name is grant cardone you are in the
cardone zone
where i wake you up i shake you up i
punch you in the face
but mostly i'm that good uncle now i was
doing a meeting
uh at the book expo last week
and there was a guy with me his name's
ryan coogler and we just met mcgraw-hill
about my book and i'm like hey look i'd
like you to take a look at the book now
i don't think mcgraw-hill is going to
talk to me about my book but i'm going
to take a shot pitch the deal
show up right the guy's like no problem
send it to me tuesday i'll take a look
at it i like this
okay and i'm like good i go back to my
little iphone my blackberry whatever it
is
right and i start texting a message ryan
says
what are you doing i said i'm emailing
the guy right now he's like great grant
you left the guy 30 seconds ago i said
yeah i know i'm emailing him right now
man i want to follow him up man
he said well you said it's too soon
grant can't do it it's not going to look
professional
i said ryan you know why i know you're
wrong he's like how i said if i call 100
people over here
and ask a hundred people is it too soon
to contact this guy i guarantee you 100
people
will agree with you and that's how i
know
you're wrong and see how many of you got
kids
okay just watch how many times a day you
practice the word no
with your kids
it's in bread to like keep no don't hate
don't do that
that's a no how many agree that counts
as a no yeah don't touch that
is it a note yeah little three or four
year old kid hey touch this touching
that he wants to touch everything why
the kid's got reach
man the kid's alive he's more alive than
the adult is now
he's interested in everything [ __ ]
what's that now what's this wow man
right check this out man right and the
mom's like hey hey
stop it don't touch that don't touch
that
don't touch that don't touch that that's
not yours
put it down don't touch yourself
no no no no and the next thing you grew
you grew up 30 years later and what are
you saying
no no don't do that don't touch that
it's not safe be careful
drive careful well careful be careful
nothing comes to people that are careful
[Laughter]
nothing zero would you agree now i've
got some special bonus clips that i
think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series give me a
hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
most people are so afraid of losing that
they don't even try
you'd rather stay average because going
for greatness means you might fail
adopt this mindset it's better to know
and to fail
than not to know all of your heroes
failed on their path to success and if
you are
unwilling to risk failure for greatness
you will stay
on your exact same path that you're on
right now so i was recently faced with
an impossible choice
where i didn't know the outcome where
two people who i respected told me
opposite bits of advice and it was
around splitting up my youtube channel
i have had my youtube channel my main
one for over 10 years it's crazy
10 years of creating content i got up to
making three videos a day
on my main channel i get on a call with
matt guelin who's one of
four people in the world who if they
gave me advice on youtube i would
really strongly deeply think about it i
respect him
and three other people that much and he
told me evan
you need to split up your channel evan
doing three videos a day
on the same channel hurts you and you
should split it up into multiple
channels
that was an impossible choice i mean for
me it was it was
scary it was difficult i don't know the
outcome
so i asked some other friends of mine
somebody else in the top four
and he says that is the biggest mistake
you could make
don't do it it's a huge mistake for your
channel
it'll hold you back so now what do i do
there's four people in the world whose
opinions i respect and trust on this one
topic
and two of them are giving me exact
opposite
what advice i do for me the decision was
easy
the action was difficult it was tough
but we do tough things
right we're entrepreneurs here's my
decision-making process
i would rather know and fail than not
know going my current course of making
three videos a day on one channel
i know what that looks like i'm liking
my success i'm liking my growth
but splitting up my channels and going
down to one video a day on my main
channel
i didn't know if they would work and if
i don't try
i'll never know so even though one
person i really respect tells me it's
the biggest mistake of my life
it may be it may be the worst decision
that i ever make
in my youtube career but i won't know
unless i try
and would rather live my life without
regrets
knowing that i got the information
instead of being afraid to act
and so i split it up and listen right
now it's actually not working
right now the views on my main channel
are down the subscribers on my main
channel are down
the amount of money i make for my main
channel is down and my other channels
like this one
haven't grown enough to combat it
to replace it but i'm still soldiering
on
i'm still continuing down this path now
if it's a year and it's still the same
thing
okay maybe i have to go back to my old
strategy but at least
i would know and so you can look at that
and say well you lost all that
opportunity
yeah i made a mistake but i'd rather
know
and fail than not know because if you
only take
safe bets if you only take the bets that
you know you're going to win at with 100
certainty then you play small for life
then you're only going to take on the
projects
that there's zero risk of failure at
which means you stay in this tiny circle
i don't want to live in a tiny circle i
want to change the world i want to have
a huge impact that comes with a great
deal of failure
just like all your heroes so i'm living
it right now this video
speaks to me and hopefully we come out
on the other side
but if not we'll go back to what we're
doing because it's not fatal
so i have a three-step process that i
want you to follow right now to take
some action and not just watch another
video
step number one what impossible choices
in front of you right now what's the
super difficult decision that you're
trying to figure out right now
where you don't know if this is gonna
work or this is gonna work people are
telling you to do different things and
you have
uncertainty around it what is that one
choice for you number two which would
you regret
more if you don't do it so look at your
two options i could do a or b
which would you regret more if you don't
do it
so for me if i did not split up my
channel i would regret it i would regret
not knowing
i would regret not knowing so i had to
go up and do it it made the decision
easy
doesn't mean that doing the steps is
easy
emotionally it's very difficult but the
path was clear and that i had to go off
and do it so between your two choices
which one would you regret more if you
don't do it and number three how can you
make it
not fatal and limit the downside so if
you take that choice that you're afraid
to do that you might regret if you never
try
how do you make it not fatal so that if
it totally goes to crap
if it's zero you get no results it's
negative you spend
all this time on something that doesn't
work out how do you make it so it's not
fatal for you
how do you limit the downside i still
have my main channel
it's not gonna go as well as potentially
all these other channels right it'd be
better if everything was combined
potentially
but i still have my main channel right
whatever choice is in front of you
how do you just get started don't go out
and necessarily take on a huge loan
mortgage the house
a second third and fourth time right
start with your energy your hustle your
drive your ambition
how do you make it so that you just get
started you limit the downside
if it doesn't work out it's not fatal
you can still move on with your life
the biggest risk is not taking a risk at
all i love it so many people are so
afraid
to follow their dreams to have this big
idea that they have that they want to go
off and accomplish
we have this big vision for ourselves
and we're so afraid of making the wrong
decision
that we do nothing that you see this big
goal
and you have three four or five
potential paths and you have limited
resources limited time limited money
limited
abilities and you want to say i need to
make the perfect decision
because if i make the wrong one it all
falls apart
and as a result we get paralyzed by fear
and we do nothing and that's the biggest
risk of all
that's when you see somebody else making
tons of money off your ideas that's when
you fast forward 10 years and you still
haven't done anything
you're still in the exact same position
that you are now meanwhile lots of
people have taken that idea that
you had and are crushing it and so
the way to get over it is to recognize
that as soon as you get an idea you need
to find some small way to test it
and that you don't have all the answers
and that's okay and that you're going to
figure it out along the way
don't be naive like i was
to think that you can create a business
plan and it's going to be the perfect
business plan
you're going to have all the answers
figured out and then you're just going
to execute that business plan
because as soon as you finish writing
your business plan and you get out into
the world and you start
testing your assumptions you'll find out
that you made a lot of mistakes that a
lot of what you thought would happen
didn't happen you couldn't predict the
future you couldn't predict how
customers would react
you can't come up with the perfect plan
just sitting in your apartment sitting
on your couch
going to the library you have to
actually get out and start talking to
customers
test your assumptions that was my
biggest problem in my first business
i spent three months working on the
perfect business plan and then when i
got out to market i realized a lot of
what i thought was going to happen
a lot of what i thought with the
reactions would be is now it actually
happened
and that set me behind and so being
attached to that perfect idea
understand that that doesn't exist there
is no perfect plan there is no perfect
idea
as soon as you get something in your
head as soon as you get an idea for
something to do
then find some small way to get out and
start testing it
find some small way to get out and start
seeing are you getting yeses are you
getting traction do you even
enjoy this a lot of times these big
goals that we have for ourselves
when you get into it you want to be a
youtuber great you start making videos
you're like yeah i don't really like
that
go figure that out as soon as possible
people wait years before they go out and
try their first attempt at it
and then they realize you know what that
wasn't for me and so i strongly
encourage you
to one as soon as you get an idea for
something something you want to test out
something that you think might work
find some immediate way to test it on a
small scale
don't take a big risk don't go mortgage
your house don't go take out a giant
loan
i hate spending money telling making
money find some small way to get started
and then two use the fear of regret use
that idea of that if i don't do anything
that in
in 60 years you're gonna look back in
your life and say i really wish that i
took some action on it
i'll give you a concrete example of what
i'm going through right now
with youtube i feel like this is my
moment
i feel like i know what i'm doing i feel
like i have my window
however long it's going to last it could
be six months 12 months
24 months i got to push as hard as i can
i feel like we're really hitting it i
think it's a
great combination of everything that i
love doing my skill sets my interest my
passion right now
to provide value to myself and to you
guys and so that's why i'm pushing hard
i'm making three videos a day
i go to my website i had a
shift where i said you know what i want
to solve the world's biggest problem
untapped human potential what does that
look like i don't know
when i first launched it i had no idea i
deleted my entire website threw up one
picture and that was my home page
if you go right now you'll see it's
still a bunch of pictures i add a little
bit more meat to the bones
but i still don't know where it's going
i don't have all the answers around it
i'm still trying to figure it out
but i figure it out by doing by testing
by having conversations
and so from a seo perspective my website
sucks but i wasn't interested in the
direction i was going anymore
i switched and so i had to find a way to
get started and so i did it myself
my website has now what i call a circle
potential and all those points you can
click on it
and dive a little bit deeper somebody
made a comment
when he clicked on the first version of
my self-awareness button he said well
it's only promoting your stuff it should
have a wider
range you're right
i don't know the answer yet i'm figuring
it out
and so i don't let the fear of making
mistakes
prevent me from doing anything because
if i waited until i had the whole thing
figured out
what the perfect website would look like
i'd never launch it and having a website
that's not complete
and building some momentum with it
drives me to want to do more on it
drives me when i figure out more details
on it and so some pages are more worked
out than others
but all of them need a lot more work and
it just came from that initial idea that
initial thesis
that as soon as you have an idea for
something you find immediate ways
to take action on it because the
momentum is so so so so so
important the biggest risk of all is not
taking any risk at all
when do you quit you quit when you don't
love it anymore
if you quit now but you still love it
you will regret that decision the rest
of your life
you'll constantly wonder what if i just
gave it one more day
one more week one more month you might
have to slow down
and do something else to survive but you
have to keep going
if you still love it so i look at my
early days as a youtube creator
and you can go back on my channel and
see how awkward i was
and nervous i was and my first video i'm
sitting down in the suit and the tie and
uh and i'm sweating and i'm trying to
memorize my lines and
took me all day to make one video most
of my lines were me reading
because i couldn't memorize the entire
script and i was so afraid of not having
to be
perfect with my lines and so i read most
of it and had
b-roll on top of it but still it took me
a whole day just to get some of those
lines out on cameras like take after
take after take after take after take
and when i started on paper it looked
like a stupid idea
i had no video background i was i'm i'm
introverted
it doesn't come across now but i'm
introverted i don't like
being the center of attention i don't go
in and talk to people and introduce
myself
i don't like the camera being on me i
don't like being in a spotlight it
doesn't
doesn't make me feel amazing about
myself i don't crave it
i'd much rather be at home by myself
you know with my wife that's super
comfortable for me that that's easy
so when i started it was just an
experiment
and even though i wasn't very good at it
i just loved it
i don't know i liked it i'm a visual
learner
and i think people are built to serve
right and
i struggled so much as an entrepreneur
that i i wish there was more content
for entrepreneurs that was visual and
that modeled success
bill gates saved my company not not me
talking to him or him investing in my
business just his story how he started
i applied and that started growing my
company and i wish there were more
resources telling the stories of
successful famous entrepreneurs that you
could learn from
one just get inspired to say wow look
what they can do but two also to get
specific ideas to help you grow your
business
and it didn't exist and so i thought i'm
gonna go make it right typical
entrepreneur nothing
exists in the market so i'm gonna go off
and create it myself
and so it made me do all these things
that i was afraid of that i wasn't good
at that didn't have natural talent and
it took me five years to get to my first
7 000 subscribers
right think about that journey now i
wasn't doing it every day i wasn't as
hardcore committed i was experimenting
and playing with it a bunch before
actually taking it seriously but i loved
it
even though i love it like as much as
i'm afraid to get in front of the camera
or afraid to go and do a speech
because i don't want to disappoint
people i still love it i love it i love
serving i love helping people this is
what i this is what i need to do
and so even though i wasn't seeing a lot
of momentum or attraction at the
beginning
even though all this stuff on paper
looked like it was against me
and i should quit and i should go do
something else
for whatever reason in my heart told me
i can't quit now i have to
keep going and just through sheer
perseverance
and and adjusting and developing the
skill set and getting better and
becoming more skilled i slowly got
better
and now here we are you know my main
channel has over 2 million subscribers
and 300 million views and it's only
because i didn't quit on my dreams
when everybody else would have quit and
i want the same thing for you
if you still love the thing that you're
doing it may not make sense right now
it may not be practical right now you
don't know how it's all going to work
out awesome
you have to keep going or you're going
to regret it just quick story i remember
meeting the friend of mine
in orlando a number of years ago just
just as i was about to start
taking off so maybe five years ago or so
in orlando
and he was telling me that that he's
gonna be the next gary vee
and and that i'm gonna go off and be the
next big youtuber
and let's go build this thing and like
cheer each other on
and he posted something maybe two years
ago
on his instagram saying i met evan in
orlando and he showed you know posted
the picture of us having a
you know starbucks in orlando and i told
him i was gonna be the next garyvee and
he was gonna go off and be the next big
youtuber
and evan went off and did it and i
didn't do my part
he just didn't have enough momentum he
just stopped start and stopped and start
and stopped and he didn't do it
and he has a lot more natural talent
charisma energy um
than i do i think we both have an equal
level of kind of care and love and
wanting to serve and help but
he he was way more gifted naturally than
me the only difference is i just kept
going
i loved it and i didn't want to quit on
it and now he regrets that he didn't
take the action now he's off doing it
he's chasing his dreams down he's
he's back on the horse and creating more
content trying to be that next person
but he regrets not having hustled as
much as i did over the
you know three four years between us
meeting and i don't want that for you
you've got a dream energy passion you
know you can give something great to the
world
if you love it you have to find a way to
keep going if you don't love it quit
immediately like get out of that
business if you hate it if you love it
it just hasn't worked out yet
you have to keep going okay so it's a
three-step process to know if you should
quit and how to keep the momentum going
on your dreams
let's go step number one is make the big
decisions in your life with your heart
and the small ones with the head
big decisions with the heart small ones
with the head here's the thing
your head is designed to keep you safe
your head only understands a world that
currently exists it's logical
it's practical it's survival mode it
keeps you safe it knows what already
exists
the problem is your heart wants to
create something new your heart is
telling you to go off and do something
that's never been done before
so the fact that you want to step
outside what your parents have done
and what your community does what your
family has done is not safe
is not practical is not logical you want
to create and burst something new that's
what entrepreneurs do
so often the big ideas that you have
your head and your heart are they're not
aligned they're fighting
your heart wants to do this thing you
love it you know it's inside you like i
gotta make this thing
but your head saying you can't do that
you don't have the school schooling
education resources connections
money you can't go off and do that go
get the safe job
right and so often the head wins out
because we live in scarcity but your
heart knows you're capable of more and
you're frustrated with your life
you have to make the big decisions in
your life with your heart we're not
making some lists of pros and cons
that's your head thinking
don't do that big decisions with your
heart and then you use your head to help
you figure out the plan
like your heart tells your head we're
doing this
head we're doing this okay no options
now help me figure out you're the smart
one
help me figure out how to actually make
it happen big decisions in life
with your heart small ones with the head
number two is understand that your
purpose comes from your pain this is a
key theme in my new book built to serve
your purpose comes from your pain your
purpose is to help other people who
currently are what you used to be
think about what you struggled with what
you suffered through there are so many
people who are currently struggling with
the exact same thing
you represent hope to them you can help
them you can guide them you can save
them
but you have to be out there creating so
if the idea that you have the dream that
you have
is in service to the people who
currently are who you used to be
and you're going to reach back and help
them you have to keep going that
that's going to fill you up for life i
love helping entrepreneurs so much
because i struggled so much as an
entrepreneur in my first business when i
felt worthless
i love modern success and and teaching
you guys
about all these famous entrepreneurs and
what they've done because that's how i
got out of the hole that i was in
right bill gates saved my first company
his story did
right so that's all i've done now for
the past 20 years 20 years
of trying to now get back and help out
other entrepreneurs
and so if your purpose in your business
and what you want to create
is coming from that pain point that you
went through and you want to help others
not suffer as much
you have to keep going because that's
going to fill you up for the rest of
your life and number three is ask
yourself what would you do if money
wasn't a problem
a lot of times we quit because money is
a problem and that is a practical
reality of
being an entrepreneur money is often a
problem you haven't figured out yet how
to make it a success you haven't figured
out with my youtube channel at the
beginning
i didn't know how to make it a success i
wasn't making any money i wasn't getting
any views
no comments no subscribers right you
haven't figured out the path yet
but if money wasn't the problem what
would you do would you still be doing
the same thing
this is what often separates the people
who just have the maniacal commitment to
keep going
and have the momentum and energy
sustained to keep going
where most logical sane people would
quit and give up because they just
love the thing that they're doing so
much if the reason you're doing it is
just chasing opportunity
you're gonna lose you should quit if
you're just chasing an opportunity
because
because this year is the year of xyz
right whatever product or service if
you're just chasing down an opportunity
then get out because you're going to go
up against people who love what they're
doing
right if it's you who's just chasing
opportunity going up against somebody
who loves the thing
you're going to lose they're going to
beat you every time you might have this
small tiny window of success
and then you have to hop to the next
thing hop to the next thing and hop to
the next thing never have any sustained
success
because you don't actually love the
thing that you're doing and you're gonna
come home and be
frustrated and angry and upset and never
really fulfilled
so the reason that you're chasing down
the thing money is important it's just
not number one
it's gotta be in your top five but if
you had all the money in the world
what would you spend your time doing and
then make sure that whatever business
you're in right now
is just a smaller version of what you
would be doing because that's the dream
that you want to work towards
if you want to sign up for the entire
billionaire mindset series for free and
get the companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there